how's it going everyone venom is so
close to being in theaters and like I
said in one of my previous videos the
closer we get to it the more promotions
we're going to see for it more trailers
more photos being released more posters
being released they're going to do
everything they can to get everybody as
psyched as possible for the new movie
coming out real quick don't forget about
the giveaway I'm doing giving away a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia as well from our
partners at silk and cotton everyone's
chasing cotton so again we're getting
closer a lot more promotional campaigns
going on today we got this crazy awesome
new poster this poster kind of has a
little bit of everything
obviously venom is the biggest on it
because it's venom
it's what the movies about and Tom Hardy
is in the middle as well because he is
venom also we also have Michelle
Williams whose plane and Wayne who is
the love interest in this movie and we
also have R is a med who is dr. Carlton
Drake who of course is the villain if
you look in the back left they actually
have a spaceship which means they could
potentially show us a team going into
space and collecting the symbiotes or
the symbiote somehow sneaking onto the
spaceship and then it comes back to
earth whatever it may be it seems like
this movie might take us into space a
little bit as you can see the rocket is
taking off in this poster and then in
the bottom left you have venom and riot
ripping each other apart and if you zoom
in close enough you can actually see
Eddie Brock inside the Venom symbiote
and dr. Carlton Drake inside the riot
symbiote this is something that we got a
little glimpse of in one of the latest
venom trailers that came out and I know
a lot of people are skeptical about this
movie but really the trailers look
amazing this poster looks amazing a lot
of the other posters that have come out
look fantastic and I'm really excited
for this movie I really hope it's a good
movie let me know what you all think
about this new poster that was released
and let me know how excited you are to
see venom when it comes
another reminder about the giveaway all
I have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]